hi everyone my name is Danny wrench and
I'm a chess master
and like most chess masters whenever our
game gets featured on the big screen I
pay extra close attention to whether or
not they got the details right now on
the scale of everything from searching
for bobby fisher' which was still by far
the greatest ever chess adaptation to
the big screen the scenes from Aladdin
where they literally took a banana to
the face because they didn't even have a
King on the board I'm gonna go through
some different chess scenes from movies
and TV shows here and let you know
whether or not they got a pass or a
failing grade from me as a chess master
let's dive in the chess scene from
Disney's Aladdin now as I said this is
pretty much gonna be a banana to the
face as far as chess goes because when
we zoom in here to the genie and the rug
we see that there's not even a King on
the board and that the magic carpet is
not playing by such magical rules there
you go thanks Robin
one of the many chef scenes now from the
movie searching for Bobby Fischer
now I actually scoured the chess scenes
that are many in this movie to show you
one that I think is a hidden gem and
really displays the level of detail they
went to in this very very brilliant
four-move checkmate combination made his
four moves from the position in front of
you that's a legit four-move checkmate
combination the move is Knight to c8 and
after a king da eight Queen a six you'll
actually pay very close attention you'll
see that there was a queen on the a file
and after the Queen's trade rook takes a
6b takes a 6 and Bishop to c6 is
checkmate though not only did they get
the board setup right they're actually
delivering high-level checkmate patterns
in this will make it easier for you Bart
Simpson's chess imal from The Simpsons
now one of the first things we notice is
the chessboard is actually set up wrong
there was a black square on the right of
every one of those chess boards strictly
checkmate
but they do they do get the real-life
adaptation of chess right in that if a
little boy without much experience
decides he's gonna play a chess silent
party he's probably gonna lose every
game I'm gonna give it a fail because
the chess board was set up wrong sorry
Bart now we're gonna take a look at some
of the many chess scenes from the x-men
films and the what I want to start with
is actually my favorite and it might be
the only one they really nailed
perfectly this battle here between
Charles Xavier and of course Magneto
starts with a pretty awesome combination
rook takes Iain if you look closely he
was actually removing a knight that's
important because the knight from EA
twould actually guard the g7 square
foolish law oh I get some fun dialog
here but here comes the pawn to g7 and
you see delivering a check to the King
on h8 is why removing that night from e8
was important though of all the chess
scenes from the x-men's that I've seen
this is this is one of the the best
you're the pawn is going to recapture
there and Charles Xavier was gonna
deliver checkmate okay so this
unfortunately goes from Charles Xavier
brilliance to what I think is an epic
fail if we look closely there I'm pretty
sure the king and queen are set up wrong
and we might even have a dark square on
the right because yeah yeah there's
definitely king and queen ER set up
wrong so we're gonna get a fail there
too uh Professor X the second go-around
we'll be watching okay nothing like a
beautiful line and you get the poems
goes at least they got that right Hans
do go first
good job magneto making up for your loss
earlier now I'm not sure where we're
headed with this but looks like a real
chess park
although if I had to guess you wouldn't
see pieces like that in a chess park
looking closely at least briefly there I
think I think that looked like a pretty
real chess position so we'll give him
that as far as the passing grade goes
there now as our old tired magneto looks
in we realized he's trying to do a
little more than just play a normal
chess game okay take a look right here
though it's like they flipped the board
the black squares on the right against
nation though they went from passing to
failing with however they decided to do
that camera angle and again even though
they get a passing grade for this board
I can see a dark square on the left the
actual position itself wasn't that clean
so surprising maybe many x-men fans from
this chess masters point of view other
than that first game with Xavier
delivering the brilliant combination the
rooks sacrificed to the knight and then
the g7 checkmate most of these chess
games are actually not that realistic
from the x-men and okay hopefully
hopefully we get a good one here let's
zoom in what do we got the board looked
to be set up properly so that's good
initial passing grade
white square on the right not sure that
a young Charles Xavier would ever put
his queen on pre to the black King but
then again they had had a few a little
bit of Scotch there and I'm not even
gonna show I'm not even gonna try to
interpret this one this doesn't even
look I don't know what's going on with
that chessboard
this was the obligatory new director and
the x-men franchise got to make sure we
get that chess scene and let's move on
from the x-men next we have the chess
scene from the very very infamous 2001 a
Space Odyssey here we go
Frank is struggling anyway clean takes
pawn bishop tanks not already a bad sign
when your queen is taking pieces on the
wrong side of the walls your opponents
attack in your king look King 1 I'm
sorry Frank I think you missed they do
get credit Queen to Bishop three Bishop
takes proper enunciation of old-school
descriptive notation and it does seem
that howl is close to a fourth segment
there I know there's been those who've
analyzed this position and claimed Frank
had a way to delay the the checkmate I
don't have enough of a close-up view to
actually say that but I will still give
2001 a Space Odyssey a passing grade for
that what seems to be a pretty high
level game of chess by hell the chess
scene from Independence Day beautiful
day in the park and then it's to be a
surprisingly organized type of chess
clock they have given that it is a part
inherently in New York somewhere my
social security will expire you still be
sitting there thinking okay and as
goldblum deliberates before pushing this
pawn now if you pause right there you
can actually see that moving the pawn to
e4 opened up the Queen along the c1 h6
diagonal and now as we take a peek in we
can see Geoff clearly preparing to bring
the Queen to that h6 Square reported by
what I think was a rook on h3 now
obviously his father is quickly making
moves could he has other things on his
name like lecture English thought about
moving on from his divorce
I'm only saying I think as far as chess
goes this is pretty high-level stuff
something I would put up there with the
glass chess set seen from the x-men and
maybe even a combination worthy of some
of our searching for Bobby Fischer chess
scenes here we see Jeff Goldblum played
Queen takes g6 which is indeed actually
checkmate given that we know the book
was on the H file so as far as the
independence chest scene goes a very
very big thumbs up from this chess
master the chess seen from the Thomas
Crown Affair 1968 edition
[Music]
okay first thoughts looks pretty good
they've they've got a chessboard that up
what seems to be post battle in the
background let's jump ahead to where the
action starts no complains that's how
most people look when they lean up and
do a chessboard that's normal
okay here we go real chess being played
now double King pawn opening can't cants
antis to that and we've got natural
developing moves here so something tells
me that they had an actual chess
consultant on this film that's about as
good as it gets openings we see played
at the highest levels of chess still
today and now he grabs his Bishop which
looks to me like he went for either the
Rory Lopez nothing like a good Spanish
game or the Italian but either way this
this chess game is gonna get a big
passing grade from me as long as they
can keep this up because right now
that's a real chess position real
structure and oh no looks like they went
backward how is that King back on its
original square and when you move a pawn
after your Queen gets attacked normally
that's a bad idea so this typically
happens in a lot of chess scenes chess
movies where they bounce around right
the chess consultant on site gave them
some good advice and then when the
editors actually get together lose all
track of the timeline of the actual
chess game so I'm still gonna give the
Thomas Crown Affair a thumbs up not just
for the chess usual tension that was
going on between those two characters
but for the fact that they had the board
set up right played a pretty serious
opening and despite that last-second
gaff where they clearly went back in
time on the board I think overall that
was a pretty good adaptation of our game
of Kings just seen from the Big Bang
Theory my catapult flings my bishop okay
I don't even know how I'm gonna comment
on this one
he's gorilla too but it looks like a
variation of chess I'd like to play okay
rook to transporter pad this is what
happens when you get that old-school
chess set and a bunch of mixed mass
Peete pieces and you don't even have
enough chess pieces for a real game so
you invent your own rules something my
three-year-old does well allowed to use
the golf cart
but when it's done charging your you
land on the time machine obviously
obviously
oh beekeeper to King 12 okay I don't
even know how I'm supposed to comment on
this but let's just say it's good
anytime chess is played on the big
screen we're gonna give it a failing
grade but not because we didn't love it
knew I should've given my Pope's a
jetpack
just seen from Star Trek what generation
stardate fifteen thirty five point eight
fifteen thirty saw quiet quarters
notified of the mysterious loss of
science probe Bessel and Terrapin
[Music]
[Applause]
your mind I think yeah yeah now this is
actually a version of chess called space
chess that does exist although not
normally played like this and again
check okay now
checkmate okay well huge failure if I'm
backing up what just happened there
between mr. Spock and mr. Shatner what I
think I heard was a check from Spock
inspire Shatner did not move his king or
do anything to get out of check a second
check in a row by Spock and then instead
of getting out of check himself Shatner
delivers checkmate only to get the
brilliant line from Spock about
Shatner's ridiculous way to play the
game but okay
sorry Trekkie fans big time fail for a
show that you think could have got chess
rightly mathematic Charlie you put the
white here in the black on a secondary
we got boring is this plan very well I
didn't know we were in for a sequel
let's go haven't seen this yet
[Music]
that was mistake charlie advance
checkmate
what isn't
[Music]
you'll excuse me
I'm gonna guess there's a little more to
this story than the chess game because
Darlie doesn't seem to be the most
mentally balanced character I've ever
seen hood stuff track up like whoa
mind melts literally Billa fail grade
sorry Trekkies moving on chess scene
from The X Files okay
first glance white is on the right we've
got an actual chess board and what looks
to be a legit clock not the worst body
language moving of a piece either
where's the kid going got to play queen
g3 if you're gonna finish this combo
okay that doesn't make sense how did he
reach for a rook on c1 and move it to g8
okay
sacrifices were crunchier this is okay
you don't now he goes for the Queen
okay that could have been a weird
commercial break somewhere in between so
we're gonna kind of give the x-files a
pass on that given that at the very
least it looks like he's about to finish
off the combination appropriately the
original Brooke sacrifice he did and
here comes Queen she's 34 by 27 which is
what I first thought when I saw the
board oh quit standing this game is
cookies
the big point just seen from Seinfeld
uh-oh my organs are playing chess again
well I'm getting a little tired of this
okay so one of those characters was
mentioned depict his brain and the other
is meant to depict something else
and I like acting scenes oh sorry
so you read from a little word is the
actions put up with that for now would
it make me happy that's your move yeah
well that's trouble my friend that's big
trouble
checkmate this legit again knowing that
I can't really make out what any of
those pieces are they're very least we
have a white square on the right and it
does look like the brain triumphed over
whatever else that is supposed to
represent good for Jiri Punk we're gonna
bring this thing back to being a little
more kid appropriate with some wizards
chess from Harry Potter
with remaining teller Ronald Harry see
you that has to go on I know it not me
not a Miley you
[Music]
but am I supposed to actually give a
chess commentary of this I don't even
know what to say all I know is those
kids were once cute before the BeerBelly
set in for old rupert grint huh I'm
talking about the facial hair and the
questionable decisions for Dan Radcliffe
[Music]
I'm on the edge of my seat with the rest
of you here
check
I mean if I'm looking at the board looks
like we had a white square on the right
right so if we're looking for any reason
to give this a passing grade knowing
that that just happened I'm gonna say at
least the board was set up right in
Harry Potter Wizards chess and let's
move on from there before Ron wakes up
thanks for watching part one of our pass
or fail chess movie scene breakdown
which movie do you think had the biggest
miss of all the ones shown so far leave
us a comment down below to let us know
otherwise part two is coming your way
soon
give us that like share subscribe all
the good stuff and we'll see you around
on chess calm